ciao ciao
sto iniziando a mettere le decorazioni
per halloween messa lampada un po
paurosa con un castello pipistrelli dei
pipistrelli
poi c'è questo che in teoria non c'entra
niente con halloween il candelabro della
bella e la bestia ma facciamo finta di
niente
poi abbiamo queste questi calderoni in
cui in effetti si potrebbe mischiare
qualche sly 2 calderón zini che berlino
prima stava cercando di mangiare questa
pianta bellissima che fa i fiori
arancioni ordinato il gatto nero quindi
questa è la mia piantine di halloween
tutti non ho tantissime decorazioni
dialogo tra finite a questa scritto
eppure un cerchietto anche per te
berlino secondo te come chissà cosa
cercate dialoghino patroncino per
berlino berlino diamo uno scheletrino
diventa proviamo l'ha subita eccolo qua
ho sempre un cane bambino anzi sembra il
mantello da supereroe guai
benissimo e merlino un po di sonno
perché è cambiato l'orario e lui è
abituato a dormire prima no dopo
comunque è un po confuso e quindi pensa
che questo sia il momento per dormire
segui dormi berlino e tranquillo siete
contenti che fra pochissimo e la mia
festa preferita in assoluto ormai sapete
benissimo che mi piacciono tantissimo le
cose paolo e se seguite il mio canale
sicuramente piazzano anche a voi le cose
paura ma halloween è una festa super
fantastica secondo me ea voi piace
halloween
[Musica]
hai sentito berlino cos'era e sentito
chi è già passato c'è qualcuno alla
porta è una federa controllo
chi è c'è nessuno
sul sito si possono immaginarsi stai la
notte di halloween halloween sembra che
tutto sia così pauroso ovvero berlino al
diventi berlino si sarebbe subito
accorto
[Applauso]
ho sentito hanno pensato di nuovo lì
rimarrà li perdiamo controllare chi è
secondo te una zucca la zucca hai per
caso ordinato una zucca io no forse l'ha
ordinata merlino allora berlino sinistra
tutto berlino è comprando tutto questo
aggiunga st ce l'ha inviata a qualcuno
come regalo ma è comunque un ottimo
decorazione per halloween mi sei
piaciuto chiarita allora dove abitiamo
che quindi bellissima sta benissimo qua
grazie chiunque l'abbia in via berlino
kimi e ora possiamo chiedere alla morte
di riorganizzare il tutto peraltro
quinzi
hai sentito hanno bussato nuovamente ci
sarà questa volta ci hanno inviato un
nuovo regalo che c'è e merlino abbiamo
la zucca ci avrai notato anche riso così
facciamo un risotto alla zucca pensi
sempre a mangiare sì certo
viviamo sono uguali
penso che gemelle vabbè mettiamole tutte
quasi anco e questo solo un pochino più
cattive deve esserci qualcosa un
biglietto che ci dice chi ce le ho
mandate non ti sembra strano molto
strano soprattutto 13 st
c'è qualcosa qua dentro forse un
biglietto
forse c'è scritto che ci siamo andate
devo riuscire a toglierlo senza rompere
la zucca guarda sono riuscita tallaferro
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
questa casa appartiene ora a noi zucche
andatevene via o verrete decorati
svuotati e messi come soprammobili come
fate voi umani con noi zucche firmato
c'è o un'altra rete le zucche è uno
scherzo
r della zucca che ci scrive ma che cosa
vuole da noi fatto lui a inviarci le
zucche tu cosa ne pensi berlino non
capisco se uno scherzo o che cosa vuole
fare con noi se vuole veramente
svuotarci e metterci più verso preamboli
basta è meglio se usciamo fuori di casa
e controlliamo se ancora qua fuori
concordo andiamo controllare se ha
lasciato adesso adesso le zucche
probabilmente ancora qui vicino e magari
riusciamo a trovarlo sarà qui in
giardino o all'entrata di dire cose in
giardino ma facciamoci è tutto buio non
vedo niente forse all'entrata andiamo a
controllare allora andiamo a berlino il
prof e del e aiutante che cos'è tutto
questo baccano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bloccando la porta di casa l'uscita non
ci vogliono far uscire perché non lo
abbiamo fatto
forse perché volevo fare il risotto con
la zucca si sono arrabbiate è stata così
facile per i temi trattati come loro
trattano noi io a distruggere i
giocattoli a forma di jack sai gli
ordini
[Musica]
c'è mancato poco hanno bloccato il
passaggio ha chiuso la porta
io no ero davanti a te per che cosa
stanno facendo le zucche
mangia
adesso cosa facciamo aiuto si sono
appropriati della nostra cameretta e del
corridoio non possiamo più uscire fuori
di casa
ho un'idea dobbiamo trovare un piano per
mandare via le zucche dalla nostra
cameretta e dalla nostra casa
se ci nascondiamo tipo se prendiamo un
suolo tipo questo ce la mettiamo addosso
così magari loro pensano che sono dei
fantastici lasciamo stare perché magari
il fantasma che uno fa più paura della
zucca no ma sinceramente non mi sembri
proprio per niente un fantasma
ma sì ma se non hai i buchi per vedere
come fai a vedere dove vai
per il rapporto aspetta aspetta o per
fare altre ecco perché non mi orientava
dove dopo questo prendono il segnale
satellitare che dirigono quindi non va
bene
questo sparire secondo me questo piano
olio padrona però la tua idea di
battermi contro l'armadio no di
trasformarsi in qualcosa potrebbe essere
un buon piano ad esempio di che cosa
hanno paura le zucche del risotto del
forno è vero che gli zu che abbiano
paura del forno ma non possiamo portare
il forno alla dentro o non metterla
dentro al forno e poi visto quanto sono
grandi vogliono quelle zucche giganti
potrebbero schiacciarci e quindi
dobbiamo trovare un piano che funziona
ho avuto un'idea e se tutti travestiti
da uno di loro
ottima idea e se poi mi prendono saranno
che stai uno di loro quindi basterà che
tutti i promessi da zucca vorrei finta
di essere uno di loro
così la convincerà i ad andarsene via ok
di capire quali sono i loro piani
oppure individuerà i questo jack il re
delle zucche andare via lui e penso che
se va via il campo andranno
tutto è giusto si giustissima e mi
chiamerò sarò la recluta zucca mi
chiamerò zucca nuova oppure testa di
zucca il valore e brutale ho paura che
questo non mi posso offenderli quindi se
gli un nome più appropriato zucca dura e
scrivete voi il nome che dovrà
utilizzare vitale quando si travestirà
da zucca ok scrivetelo nei commenti il
miglior nome lo utilizzeremo giocato
n'da altrimenti pitale continuo per una
settimana a dire i nomi arancino di
zucca
non ci resta che mettere in atto il
nostro piano dobbiamo riuscire a
trasformarsi in una zucca voi lasciate
subito un mi piace
per sostenere questa missione quindi
lasciate subito un mi piace per vedere
la seconda porta a seguirmi su instagram
se ancora non mi seguite su utah il rame
tutti doc e ora vi lascio qua 4
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e ci vediamo alla seconda
parte
[Musica]